first a friend mentioned that I should
definitely talk to you and I googled you
and I saw that somebody recommended that
Jordan Peterson absolutely must talk to
you on this podcast wow
um I think there's like a Reddit post
right thank you for Reddit poster that's
that's great I was like oh interesting
and then I looked and Jordan hasn't yet
I thought
my goal is for you to talk to to Rogan
and to Jordan Peterson for for different
reasons but for the same reason they get
connected to uh a human being that
deeply cares about this Earth and I
think that's probably the right lens
through which to look at the effects of
climate change
in terms of focusing on the different
things that are threatening threatening
the diversity of species in this most
magical place on Earth which is the
Amazon but also as you'll talk about
with elephants and tigers in India
and focusing on how to solve those
problems I don't know if there's any
comment you want to make on folks like
Jordan Peterson who are sort of raising
questions about how much do we really
understand about the climate yeah first
of all I'm such a Jordan Peterson fan
and I think the guy is heroic for a
number of reasons and I I find his his
use of language and his use of Theology
and and the message that he puts out
wonderful
um I cringe a little bit when he says I
I feel like and I I might not even be
accurate on this but I cringe a little
bit when I feel like he just he
dismisses that there is an ecological
emergency happening right now now I'm
not saying I'm not talking about climate
change specifically but I've heard him
say you know environmentalists upset me
and he goes what do you mean by the
environment everything and it sort of
seems to outrage him and it's and I I
kind of agree with him there because so
are you telling me that we need to Halt
our Global process and and and and and
progress and economies and everything I
don't know I don't know and so so to me
um I I don't that doesn't bother me
because he's exploring what the hell are
these people talking about when you say
you have I have I personally have
friends and students and people filling
my inboxes I have young kids telling me
that they're they've become vegan and
they ride a bicycle and sometimes they
don't watch TV because it uses
electricity and I mean they're just
becoming so so terrified of that they're
killing the Earth and so it's this
doomsday anti-human sentimentist thing
that we're that we're evil it's like
it's almost like a new religion about
you're evil and so to me
I it almost makes me in a totally
different camp where like climate change
and the right left politics and you know
I I considered a family I considered
Thanksgiving dinner and listen to listen
to the the climate thing go back and
forth yeah and I'm like I'm not even I'm
not even here and that might actually
annoy some people
in the environmental field that might
feel betrayed by me saying that but I
don't care
my job and it's not just the Amazon and
and that's one note I wanted to make is
that
my career has has taken place largely in
the Amazon and also in India and now a
lot in Africa but it's it's not even
just these exotic places either it's
it's it's people realizing that you know
the salmon runs in Canada and the the
butterfly gardens in our backyards that
there's biodiversity everywhere and it's
and I I strongly feel like you know the
idea of
jungle Keepers the idea of of of
stewards of Nature and so for me my my
job my one thing
and I I try to tell this to these kids
that message me and that my my inboxes
are full of this where they go you know
the climate is burning and elephants are
in Decline and tigers and and this and
I'm like Oh my guys look first of all
calm down first of all like go outside
go get laid do something Have Fun
next pick something that you can affect
and it doesn't have to be with the
environment do something good on Earth
go help somebody that needs food go help
your elderly neighbor whatever it is
practice practice with being effective
at one thing at a time and so for me
like I said from those early days of
sitting there with JJ on the side of a
river and going someone has to protect
this
um my concern is that we've lost 70
percent of the wildlife on this planet
in the last 50 years that's a huge
problem Wildlife maintain the ecosystems
and so I have a very clear-cut very
definable very measurable and provable
thing that I'm fighting against and it's
a very to me it's a very like small ask
don't cut down the three percent of the
world that has 50 of the biodiversity in
it maybe let's keep some wild tigers for
future generations and because tigers
have their own inherent right to exist
here that's my thing in terms of when we
get to you know I get attacked for you
know
you should be a vegan
okay
you shall you you have me roll into a
village in the Amazon when they offer me
spider monkey and you tell me that I
should be a vegan and you you see how
much they respect you and you tell them
that you're a vegan
like
um but no so for someone like Peterson I
think it's actually good that he's first
of all telling everyone to make their
damn beds and uh and and exploring it
through a different lens you know he's
he's coming at it from a totally
different thing and saying you know are
we just being alarmist here are we what
I mean again imagine if you know that
imagine if they're
isn't a problem and they're then they're
making one out of it and all the
implications that that could have for
Progress it's like so I think what he's
doing is is perfectly reasonable
um there is a podcast though where he's
he's
it was a great one though where he's
he's discussing animal intelligence and
and I could really see that that you
know the human psyche and Theology and
and religion is so much his world that
that the the really the the idea of
animals being intelligent was novel and
it was and it was fascinating yeah
that's why I would love the two years to
talk just I don't know and hopefully I'm
not on a line here but he is so focused
on the human mind
that I think he forgets
that there's other
life out there there's this whole
machine of intelligence of a kind of
intelligence out there
this entire trillions of species tiny
and big just clothing just moving
everywhere everywhere and we're actually
part of it so like to look at a human
psychologist distinct from that is
missing at least some of the picture
some of the picture I do believe though
I would agree with him on that humans
are unique human psychology is unique we
just are but but I also you know it's
he's in such an interesting
place because usually you have
you know environmentalists who are like
you know nature nature nature and then
you and that's very anti-human
and then you have the other side and
it's like he's he's he's on this path
where he's he's starting to explore what
those like diverse intelligences mean
and that that to me is really amazing
because I love hearing what he'll do
with that and I think also on top of
that
I think if you're aware of nature
deeply aware of nature it gives you
another perspective on their
evolutionary history of humans
it's one thing to be an evolutionary
biologist and kind of study it from a
like philosophical perspective and it's
the other to really I think experience
it and deeply know it to see I don't
know
the fact that we came from fish should
really be cognizant of that that's
something else that's like
I don't know uh to realize that we're
part of a Computing machine that created
intelligence report well part of the
thing that started bacteria and is now
creating AI